الشرق والجنوب جبهتان في اوكرانيا هما
الاكثر التهابا تتحدث سوره الروسيه في
اقليم دمباز عن قصف صاروخين اوكراني تكثف
على مقاطعه كيف تونيت سكولوجان
جنوبا ما تزال تتصدر المشهد حديث القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تقدم مستمر
تيار الكهربائي والمياه جراء القصف واعمال
كما تؤكد ارجاء عشرات الالاف من سكان
المقاطعه
للامر حكما صله بتنبيه موسكو الى حشد
الاوكرانيين مدرعات على محور خرسون
يقرا الرؤوس في ذلك تاهبا لهجوم وشيك يروم
استعاده المقاطعه التي سقطت في ايديهم في
بدايه الحرب ثم ضموها مع ثلاث مقاطعه اخرى
الى اراضيهم في استفتاءات سبتمبر المثيره
للجدل
هي احداث تلك المناطق وفي تقدمه البطيء
هناك تشكل مدينته فخمه الى الشمال اهميه
خاصه للجيش الروسي
يوصف محور مدينه باخبط بانه اعنف جبهات
القتال في اقليم دومباز خصوصا مع التمكن
القوات الروسيه من الوصول الى مشارف
المدينه
والمدينه الاستراتيجيه تكشف وسائل الاعلام
روسيه عن تمركز للقوه فاجنر على بعد
كيلومترين منها يقول قائد الميداني في
المجموعه ان قوته سيطرت على بلدتين
ملاصقتين للمدينه من جهه الجنوب لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول صدها
نحو 80000 قبل بدء الحرب والان اضحك شبه
فارغه بعد الاصاب الدمار معظم اجزائها
وبينما يستعروا القتال حول المدينه
المحاصره تتفاقم الماساه الانسانيه لمن
اختاروا البقاء او اجبروا عليه يقولون
انهم صامدون على امل ان تتمكن القوات
الاوكرانيه من ابعاد من يص فونهم بالغذاء